president Trump downplayed senator
Kamala Harris's attack on Joe Biden
during the democratic debate Thursday
nights
his remarks came as Bachmann tried to
press the reset button on Friday and
pledged to veto a president who stands
against racism Harris had sharply
criticized Biden for defending his
opposition to federally mandated busing
more than 40 years ago
here's that Oh Keith I want to be
absolutely clear about my record of
position on racial justice including
busing I never never never ever opposed
voluntary busing former Vice President
Biden in Chicago trying to explain away
a tough moment for him I did support
federal action to address root causes
segregation in our schools in our
communities as a young senator in the
1970s by didn't believe that busing
wouldn't help achieve equal opportunity
he frequently spoke out about the issue
including at a press conference 42 years
ago I don't think it should be left to
any bureaucrat in any agency including
even if it were the Justice Department
on stage California senator Kamala
Harris called out Biden for opposing
federally mandated busing to desegregate
schools and his past work with
segregationist senators it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two United States senators who built
their reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country
there was a little girl in California
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day and that
little girl was me if we want to have
this campaign litigated on who supports
civil rights and whether I did or not
I'm happy to do that
moments later Harris's campaign tweeted
a photo of her as a young girl on CBS
this morning
Harris explained why she raised the
issue my purpose and in raising my
experience is was to really just make
sure that in this conversation we are
appreciating the impact on real people
of policies that
have been pushed in in the history of
our country meanwhile Harris had some
explaining of her own to do on Friday in
the debate Thursday night she backed a
proposal that would abolish private
insurance in favor of her government
backed plan but by Friday she was
clarifying saying that private insurance
would still exist if she had her way but
just for supplemental coverage for CBS
this morning Saturday at O'Keeffe
Washington